queridos amigos y si os dijera que Texas
podría llegar a independizarse de
Estados
Unidos No no es ninguna broma igual que
ocurre con los movimientos
independentistas de Escocia Quebec o
Cataluña Estados Unidos también tiene su
propia versión de todos esos embrollos
políticos fijaos Tejas un paso más cerca
de abandonar Estados Unidos Sí tal y
como lo estáis oyendo Aunque resulte
difícil de creer Texas tiene su propio
movimiento independentista uno
nostálgico con aquella Tejas
independiente que logró separarse de
México en 1836 y que desapareció en
1845 con la adhesión a Estados Unidos de
hecho a semejanza del brexit al caso de
Texas algunos lo conocen ya como texit y
ojo porque esto no es una ida de Hoya Sí
el movimiento es pequeño pero está
cogiendo fuerza y desde luego sucesos
como los acontecidos en las últimas
semanas no ayudan precisamente a calmar
los ánimos se intensifica el
enfrentamiento fronterizo entre Texas y
los federales mientras el gobernador
desafía la decisión del tribunal supremo
Exacto el gobierno de Texas y la
administración biden han comenzado el
2024 inmersos en una fuerte disputa por
el control de la frontera de Texas con
México la situación está que arde ahora
bien exactamente qué está ocurriendo en
la frontera de Texas como para alimentar
un movimiento independentista por qué
Texas quiere ocuparse por sí mismo del
control de sus fronteras podría la
inmigración ser la gota que colma el
vaso y terminar con un movimiento
independentista bien formado Pues bien
de todo esto y más os vamos a hablar a
continuación atentos Por cierto no te
olvides de que ya hemos lanzado nuestro
nuevo canal de negocios el informe K
Muchísimas gracias a todos por la
acogida tan buena que le estáis dando si
aún no lo conocéis os dejo el link en la
descripción aquí abajo ya nos dirás qué
te
parece la eterna crisis fronteriza
si habéis estado atentos a las noticias
últimamente puede que hayáis visto
decenas de imágenes y titulares sobre la
frontera entre Estados Unidos y México y
no es para menos El Tío Sam está
sufriendo una de las peores crisis
fronterizas de las últimas décadas por
no decir de toda su historia desde que
Joe biden tomó las riendas de la Casa
Blanca en enero del 21 hasta el pasado
diciembre de 2023 la patrulla fronteriza
de Estados Unidos ha interceptado a más
de 6 millones de personas habéis oído
bien 6 millones es como si en menos de 3
años un país entero como Dinamarca
quisiera entrar ilegalmente en Estados
Unidos como os podéis imaginar con
semejante percal las autoridades
fronterizas están desbordadas tan solo
en diciembre de 2023 han llegado a
procesar a 10,000 personas por día de
locos pero es que es más aún así según
los datos del departamento de seguridad
nacional en ese mismo periodo entre 1
millón y medio y 2 millones de
indocumentados han cruzado de manera
ilegal la frontera por por eso desde el
partido republicano se ha acusado a
biden de fomentar una política de
fronteras abiertas ahora bien es esto
realmente cierto pues no para nada Es
cierto que las peticiones de asilo
aceptadas han crecido con respecto a la
era Trump Pero esto se debe sobre todo a
que simplemente se han disparado las
solicitudes de hecho a grandes rasgos la
administración biden está llevando una
política migratoria bastante continuista
con la del gobierno de Trump por ejemplo
ha mantenido el acuerdo con México por
el que los deportados por Estados Unidos
son llevados directamente a su vecino
del sur además la inversión en seguridad
fronteriza y aduanera también se ha
mantenido en el entorno de los 15,000
millones de dólares anuales incluso por
encima de esta cifra récord Algunos años
pero entonces muchos os estaréis
preguntando qué diantes está pasando por
qué se han disparado tanto las llegadas
de inmigrantes a la frontera sur de
Estados Unidos pues queridos amigos de
visual politic las razones no las vamos
a encontrar dentro de Estados
[Música]
Unidos y es que fijaos un momento En
este gráfico la situación de los países
americanos en algunos casos está empero
la corrupción la violencia y la pobreza
siguen siendo por desgracia la norma en
países como México Venezuela o en
regiones como el Triángulo Norte sobre
todo en Guatemala y Honduras puede que
solo El Salvador se salve de esta
tendencia tan negativa que se está
viendo últimamente en Ibero América es
más los que hayáis visto nuestro
reciente vídeo de Ecuador sabréis por
dónde van los tiros Y es que en estos
últimos años noticias como esta han
hecho más que multiplicarse la pobreza
extrema en la región sube 86 millones en
2021 como consecuencia de la
profundización de la crisis social y
sanitaria derivada de la pandemia de
covid-19 América Latina lucha contra una
Nueva Ola de criminalidad eso sí A
diferencia de Trump que simplemente
criminaliza a los inmigrantes biden ha
intentado atajar esta crisis poniendo el
foco en las causas de la inmigración
ilegal es decir la corrupción la pobreza
y la inseguridad por ejemplo se ha ido
sancionando a altos funcionarios
centroamericanos envueltos en
importantes casos de corrupción en lo
que se conoce como lista Engel también
la vicepresidenta camara Harris que es
la encargada de la política migratoria
en esta administración ha impulsado un
programa de inversiones de más de 4,000
millones de dólares sin embargo para
muchos todo esto está siendo inútil una
pérdida de tiempo y de dinero y es que
claro el problema que tiene apostar por
este tipo de estrategias es que los
resultados no son precisamente rápidos
quizás pueda ser una buena idea a medio
y largo plazo pero no antes y el
problema es que los estadounidenses
están ansiosos por conseguir soluciones
ya pronto y aquí es justo donde aparece
Texas con su gobernador el republicano
Greg abot para dar un puñetazo en la
mesa
[Música]
atentos
abot contra
biden recordáis que os hemos dicho que
entre 2021 y 2023 Estados Unidos
interceptó a 6 millones de inmigrantes
en su frontera Pues bien casi el 60 por
de ellos fueron interceptados en suelo
tejano por eso en 2021 el gobernador de
Texas Greg abot lanzó la operación long
Star o traducido al Castellano estrella
solitaria con esta iniciativa el
gobierno de Texas desplegó a su Guardia
nacional y otras agencias de seguridad
del estado en la frontera de esta forma
Texas empezó a tomar sus propias medidas
de acción Como por ejemplo desplegar
grandes barreras subacuáticas con boyas
en el Río Grande para impedir el paso
por el río a los migrantes y eso no es
todo el pasado diciembre de 2023 también
se firmó una ley que permitía a la
policía del estado detener a los
inmigrantes que entraran de manera
ilegal por su frontera y además de
acuerdo a esta ley los propios jueces
del Estado también podrían ordenar su
deportación algo que en Estados Unidos
llevan jueces específicos del
departamento de justicia y sí obviamente
tal y como estáis pensando eso supone
todo un desafío contra el Gobierno
Federal contra Washington y por si fuera
poco todo saltó por los aires por una
medida concreta que abot adoptó en
septiembre del 23 el despliegue de más
de 70 000 rollos de alambre de Espino a
manos de la guardia Nacional de
Texas la mayor parte del alambre de
Espino fue instalado en la localidad
fronteriza tejana de Eagle Pass más
concretamente en su orilla del Río
Grande para evitar así la entrada de los
inmigrantes ilegales desde el principio
la patrulla fronteriza de los Estados
Unidos se quejó al considerarlo un
obstáculo para sus tareas entre las que
se encontraban salvar a los inmigrantes
que se estuvieran ahogando en el propio
río Así que la patrulla fronteriza
decidió empezar a cortar el alambre de
ino de la guardia Nacional de Texas y a
raíz de ello el estado tejano comenzó a
denunciar a la patrulla fronteriza y al
gobierno de biden ante los tribunales
exigiendo que parasen de inmediato la
destrucción del alambre y lo cierto es
que esa batalla la ganaron los
tejanos ahora bien una batalla ganada no
supone una victoria en toda la guerra el
conflicto con el Gobierno Federal Apenas
ha hecho nada más que comenzar y para
prueba esto escuchad los federales dicen
que Texas está bloqueando a la patrulla
fronteriza de una una sección de la
frontera piden a la Corte Suprema de
Estados Unidos que intervenga sí la
guardia Nacional de Texas balló todo un
parque de la ciudad de igle pass y
denegó la entrada a la patrulla
fronteriza la reacción de la
Administración biden no se hizo esperar
presentaron documentos al tribunal
supremo que demostraban la importancia
de ese acceso para socorrer a los
inmigrantes que hubiesen tenido
problemas al cruzar el río y que
estuvieran en peligro de
ahogarse y no es para menos el día 12 de
enero una mujer mexicana se ahogó con
sus dos hijos menores de edad a las
orillas del Eagle Pass con esta presión
tan grande el tribunal supremo
finalmente decidió permitir a la
patrulla fronteriza retirar todo el
alambre de Espino ya que tiene
jurisdicción en todo el territorio
fronterizo del país sin embargo lo que
no hicieron fue prohibirle a la guardia
Nacional de Texas que siguiera
desplegándose
lo convertirán en otro punto de entrada
para la inmigración ilegal y en esta
especie de guerra entre Texas y el
Gobierno Federal el gobernador abot no
está precisamente solo casi todos los
gobernadores republicanos del país y el
propio Donald Trump han apoyado esta
decisión y la postura de abo de hecho
incluso han aumentado el envío de
soldados de sus propias guardias
nacionales Para apoyar al gobernador
tejano la situación como veis está Al
rojo vivo el viejo espíritu
independiente de Texas está dejándose
notar como no lo hacía en mucho tiempo y
muchos hablan ya de una posible secesión
tejana como esto termine yendo a mayores
la cuestión es es esto realmente posible
puede Texas separarse de Estados Unidos
Pues bien veámoslo
rumbo al
texit las medidas de abot en materia de
control migratorio y el encontronazo con
las autoridades de Washington DC están
en cierto modo impulsando el movimiento
nacionalista de Texas y si no me creéis
fijaos Cómo la lucha fronteriza de grek
abot refuerza los llamamientos a una
Texas
independiente el enfrentamiento de Texas
con los federales en Eagle Pass enciende
los llamamientos a la secesión y el
temor a la violencia la causa
independista tejana ha sido una de las
pocas que no murió ni quedó enterrada en
el olvido tras la guerra civil de
Estados Unidos y sí es verdad que Texas
no se implicó mucho en las batallas pero
sí que intentó independizarse en 186 un
al considerar La abolición de la
esclavitud una grave intromisión del
Gobierno Federal en sus propios asuntos
sin embargo con la victoria del Norte
Texas no pudo independizarse Eso sí poco
a poco fueron desarrollando una
identidad muy marcada una identidad muy
ligada al legado de los cowboys y al
sudeste de los Estados
Unidos de hecho A mediados de los 90
nació un movimiento conocido como
República de Texas que se autodenomina
como sí podéis creerme gobierno
provisional este movimiento fue fue
creado por Richard Lance mclaren que
denunció en incontables ocasiones al
Gobierno Federal por cosas tan locas
Como por ejemplo el paganismo es más en
1997 hasta reclamó una compensación a la
administración Clinton de más de 90,000
millones de dólares por los daños
sufridos durante la Guerra
Civil pero anécdotas aparte el legado
secesionista de Texas va más allá y está
yendo más allá hasta el punto de que a
día de hoy nos podemos encontrar
noticias como estas un legislador de
Texas presenta el proyecto de ley texit
para impulsar la votación sobre la
exploración de la secesión de Estados
Unidos Daniel Miller y miembros del
movimiento nacionalista de Texas
entregaron
139,45 firmas en la sede del partido
republicano de Austin ahora bien Qué
dice el partido republicano de todo esto
Pues bien lógicamente el partido no está
por la labor de incluir un referéndum de
Independencia de Texas en el debate
político y mucho menos hacerlo de Cara a
las primarias de marzo y si no lo hacen
no es tanto porque les guste más más o
menos la idea sino básicamente porque no
pueden una sentencia de 1869 prohíbe
tanto a Texas como a cualquier otro
estado del país independizarse
unilateralmente es decir que por mucho
que algunos políticos tejanos como Ted
cruz tonen con los que defienden la idea
de la secesión no es más que palabrería
política barata para intentar así
Mostrar su desacuerdo con Washington es
una retórica que si bien Se ha
fortalecido por el enfrentamiento entre
Texas y la administración biden no tiene
mayor recorrido la inmensa la mayoría de
los tejanos se sienten muy
estadounidenses faltaría más incluso
Aunque les encante ser tejanos ya sabéis
que vivan los cowboys de hecho es
probable que una vez se solucione todo
esto el tema vuelva a enterrarse Y
limitarse prácticamente a entornos muy
minoritarios así que ya lo veis los
sueños de los sionistas tejanos tienen
las patitas muy cortas y se quedarán
seguramente en eso en sueños pero lo que
no es tan minoritario ni intrascendente
es la dura batalla que está germinando
entre los republicanos y la
administración biden a las puertas de
unas elecciones a la casa blanca al
senado y al congreso amigos amigas las
cosas prometen estar entretenidas para
bien o para mal en los próximos meses de
momento el turno ahora es para vosotros
creéis que se calmará pronto las
tensiones entre abot y biden o Irán
todavía peor podría ganar peso La
retórica secesionista en Texas podéis
dejarnos vuestras respuestas aquí abajo
en los comentarios y muy importante si
os ha gustado este vídeo olvides darle
al botón de like y suscribiros a nuestro
canal para no perderos ninguna novedad
una vez más Muchas gracias por estar un
saludo y hasta la
[Música]
próxima